des visages démasqué dans les rues des
principales villes du pays
jusqu'à maintenant le zimbabwe et ses
quelques 14 millions d'habitants ont été
relativement épargnées par le
coronavirus une situation qui pousse le
gouvernement à assouplir les gestes
barrière à la plus grande satisfaction
des habitants comme ici à chitungwiza au
sud darar la capitale on avait
particulièrement peur pendant les trois
premières semaines du confinement mais
aujourd'hui plus du tout c'est pour cela
que je ne porte pas de masque
il n'y a plus de coronavirus mais cette
baisse de vigilance inquiète les
organisations de santé
rosemary et travailleuse communautaire
et tous les jours elle fait du porte à
porte pour sensibiliser les familles
face au danger que représente le coc
vite 19
notre travail est maintenant plus
difficile parce que les gens n'ont plus
peur
certains nous disent même qu'ils ne
craignent plus le virus parce qu'il n'a
tué personne dans leur entourage
il ajoute qu'ils ont plus peur du vih
parce qu'il a tué beaucoup de personnes
autour d'eux si le zimbabwe est aussi
peu touchés par le cos vite 19 c'est
grâce à une mise en place rapide des
mesures strictes pour endiguer sa
propagation selon les instances
sanitaires du pays
toutefois ces mêmes instances
avertissent le gouvernement n'hésitera
pas à remettre en place des mesures
restrictives en cas de résurgence de
l'épidémie